[Music]
all right so this is Harvey Illinois
it's a small town where the mayor he
frequently sends members of his own
family to the back room of a particular
strip club why is he doing that wait
what family members you said why to
divvy up the cash that he's laundering I
why he looks at me goes
why tell
me he he periodically sends his his
family in there yeah why why do you
think why do you think do that they're
collecting cash for the money laundering
damn yeah that's what I'm thinking cash
business it's not money laundering but
they are collecting cash account
cash oh it's it's Security money or some
[__] protction money it's racketeering
so the mayor of this actual Town
basically uh was collecting payouts from
the local strip club uh in order to not
shut them down because they were running
a process tion thing in the back that
makes sense that's fair game bab very
logical the weird thing is called
community so shortly after earning
position of Mayor this guy uh mayor
Kellogg he orders a strip club to pay
him 3K a month or he shuts them down um
that's not that much after a couple
years though he doubles the fee to 6,000
a month now that's more market value and
then he continues he continues to
collect this every single month for 15
years very good oh so the prices were
probably more back very good very good
well he hasn't stacked interest on if
it's 6,000 bucks for 15 years that's not
that's really good did he is he putting
any away for retirement hopefully he
being smart with the money he doing is
his landlords are worse than that
landlords will [__] go with market
value they'll keep pumping it 6,000 a
month for some safety and protection and
eh but then when they wouldn't pay or
they would like scoff at it he would
send police over there to to um
intimidate that well you got to remind
them well I mean if I was a strip club
owner I I if the police came I'll just
have uh I'll just give them [__] or
something by
myself and then and then they'll go away
smart you handle it yourself you know I
I'm I'm I'm cuz I'm not a [__] sex
trafficker I'm not going to have my
girls do it I'm going to do it myself
well the girls are going to be working
on C actual paying customer yeah they'll
be literally on the job that's right
those cops are yeah they're busy
servicing the real customers yeah true
you're man you should be a hostage
negotiator and I always believe like the
boss of the the boss of the play should
also be the master of like doing all the
stuff like they should be the best
skilled at sucking true aning whatever D
people calling you blow Joe is like sick
that's kind of how you are with Jun
right you learned how to do all the jobs
so that when you're the boss you teach
them right yep makes sense and I think
at the strip club this guy should be
doing the same thing who you [__] fix
SE your hair while you're saying P they
should the catwalk he's just like I
think I should be the master so how do
you think he starts firing strippers one
by one cuz he's like I'm really good I'm
better than you I don't need y'all I
could keep all the money if I stripped
[__] sucked and did the register and
the bartending dude you show up late
again I'm taking your clients the way
all if I strip [__]
suck show gets all sassy good old blowjo
you really you get strong and
independent when you go through these
things I like it how do you think the
mayor got caught
tattletails I'm going to say depositing
money no cash no family member rat him
out cuz they want a piece of the
pie oo almost almost I think he tried to
expand too hard you know like he was
like oh if I could do this to one strip
club maybe I could do the dispensary
down the street oh like you just get too
cocky about it yeah MH so the way that
he got caught basically was because the
strip club itself was being investigated
for the prostitution that was going on
in there he's not doing his job then FBI
yeah FBI yeah so they be but then that's
a different that's Federal different
exactly and you know the those guys they
bump yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah caution
tape exactly so they start there's this
investigation going on in the strip club
in which they started uh like wir
topping catching conversations and then
they started hearing some conversation
about like paying a a rent money or like
a pizza
tax oh they have cold words too yeah
they had cold words but then like the
dude was always like griping about
having to do it so then they were like
oh what's this so then they ended up um
working with the strip club to uh the
the FBI gave Federal like actual money
to be to start paying the the the debt
with this money to be like yeah you know
what just keep paying the money like to
these guys we can find out who they are
and like what the where the chain goes
up so that's how they end ended up
figuring out that it was uh all the way
to the mayor wow wow the mayor would
send his brother and like his cousin to
like all relatives and they didn't want
to like there's like conversations that
were recorded where the brother and the
cousin are like we don't want to do this
anymore this is like whatever and then
um the mayor was like I guess they they
caught him saying like well I don't
trust anybody so you guys have to do it
and they had all these like code words
for it but the weird thing is that now
that they've arrested the brother and
the cousin the mayor still hasn't faced
any charges for it s I mean I wonder why
maybe he's paying the FBI $6,000 a month
for another 10 years that's a good deal
though I know that Mayors can like stay
a mayor for like ever I don't know I
don't know that bro remember mayor daily
in Chicago I didn't know he was mayor
for the entire duration but when he
became mayor is when he started the oh
so he might have continued it on because
so I'm like but if you're not even oh
like you're still working in the city
well either way he had people like the
city was aware of this happening
greasing everybody he already had the
racket going so by the end after he paid
everyone out the mayor's probably only
keeping 250 bucks yeah dude pay out his
family members he has to pay the police
he has to pay what's the better way to
do it a month you for a year is 72 grand
time
15 it's not that much well assuming
though uh they were also doing 3,000 for
the first cont he has to pay the chief
of police but let's say times 15 million
dude bucks what he should have done is
got into partnership the mayor and the
family members could have been adding
more business by being more of the
strippers the employees you know what
are they doing being the employees being
the
strippers about everybody so that people
are going to see the mayor strip yeah
the Taco Town cuz you got to be the
master you got to [__] suck like Friday
nights where it's popping you know what
I mean imagine like leave from the front
so everybody the the strippers know okay
if he's willing to do it I got to do it
hey if you if you own a strip club in
Hawaii right and uh let's say it was
legit right and then uh the manager is
all hey if we start doing some shady
[__] in the back we probably make 50
times a profit I'll be
like so who I got to sucker in here like
wa you mean sucker we're talking about
doing um a distribution ring for drugs
oh drugs you must be crazy get out of
here who who do I got to suck off to get
you out of
here suck the manager said that I was
like you want to start [__] people
the manager was just talking about you
only he's like yeah I need you to suck
like 50 dudes a day yeah I'm like all
right all right all right's tying his
hair up I mean you know that's why they
say it's difficult for owner operators
to expand because you know we get so
busy that we're doing all the work we
can't we can't delegate we
micromanage we get so everything is just
we just don't know how to let it go you
know B rubbing his jaw right now he's
like godamn be a business owner is
[__] hard dud all the dicks I got to
S like Nick's black
belt what other kinds of places besides
massage places and strip clubs could you
add happy endings to I think it's very
risky to
do that at a strip club even though
that's where it is so where would you
put it that it's not a motel next to a
strip
club easy think more creatively chicken
tender shop what other places could have
it uh a tanning room yeah yeah they got
a tanning s a tanning place they just go
into the tanning bed and get jacked off
those are sketchy for so basically like
a tan line on your
dick but it's fingerprints yeah it's
meanwhile when you show up there like
everybody who's working has like the
darkest hands oh my God was that kind of
tting Blade laser laser tag laser tag
nobody would expect it so in the middle
of the game you just like go to a start
disappearing during the game and you
don't really notice cuz like it's your
laser tag people hide eliminating but
because of all the black lights when you
come back out and there's just a bunch
of stuff everywhere oh yeah all over
your pants and [__] yeah I like the idea
of getting like federally investigated
and they're like so you've been going to
laser tag a lot this year huh uh so
laser tag is that a code name he like no
no I go to laser
tag a mattress store oh oh that's good
because there's so many of those a mattr
you want to try this
mattress always going out of business
sit and sleep suck and [__] oh yeah
there you go suck and [__] sit and sleep
code words
yeah um uh um a a hair a hair wash Sal
hair wash hair wash hair wash hair wash
selfs serve hair wash is that a business
already hair
wash hair wash bagel shop
a hair
wash you go in and there's just
different stalls where you get your hair
washed it's so suspect cuz they're like
what's a hair wash is a hair wash code
no it's the business name welcome to the
hair wash uh bird [__] all over your
hair where do you
go you're a pinch so specific just a
hair wash
Salon like oh they're [__] in there
dude hair
yeah